say it on the mic
well yeah they gave us all this water
look at those cases of water
everybody has it now I want to feel
special and and I see it on so many
podcasts these days
oh yeah thank you
yeah they're different kinds you want a
different kind
of sparkling
flowered
oh yeah arguably Coca-Cola is a
different kind of water
you are I'm looking at your butt
I don't mind
I look at butts and I was it's also
bright yellow it looks like someone
highlighted your butt
I'm booming you
my wallet and everything over here
testicles spectacles
testicle spectacle spectacle testicle
spectacle do you not notice testicles
testicles no specs
spectacles testicles wallet watch it's
how you cross yourself
do you know this
you start with testicles when you cross
yourself
taking so long to sit down and if I was
how long have you been doing stuff in
here
did we start yet are you I'm so glad we
have started because this is one that
was one of my favorite
opening moments of all time
how's it so cool in here but that's not
working I mean that's not on I'm so glad
you asked
I'm fighting you oh
is it happening
the thing that when you're if you're
stoned this it's almost like ASMR
[Music]
on your show well I like it I have one
when your show starts let me know and
then we'll but I'll tell you the uh
based uh another joke off this which is
good although this was not originally a
joke I think it was just my hesitation
to do this because I'm frightened
and because of your reaction to my
outfit or non-reaction I just accepted
it yes I know
but I've watched your show I've watched
this podcast and I've and I've and I've
I've realized that
that uh that you're you know you I mean
you lay into people this is your I lay
into people
people you know you get people that's
the real sponsor of the show people's
you know some Kaka
but that's good you like loving cacao
you want what episode did you watch that
I gave
every single one of them that would have
taken you four years
this last week felt like four years
because I watched every single episode
where would you like me to put this
because I don't I'll put it over here
just don't eclipse the liquid death with
it
okay
[Music]
um
what do we start out with it so we're
just gonna start talking now
let me ask you a question who goes two
inches above a couch and then and then
re-erects people who go take ship in
public bathroom ah and women when they
tinkle
I often do sit when I tinkle
why aren't we all said my daughter my
daughter my daughter I was peeing this
morning oh I have to do this why do we
have to stand today what we have to
stand a podcast
I don't know why not here how about you
you may I'm letting you as the host like
Johnny Carson I'd go
it's not abandoning the bit if if I say
you may sit
and you had an iced coffee already
is it cold brew
let me tell you what my daughter said
tell me she's four you want this here
she's
she's like
[Music]
yes yeah yeah right I collect TV
I collected TV guides normally I'm loved
when I collect TV when I was younger
TV guides and Mad magazines and um and
here and here is one of them and so my
wife is like how long are you going to
keep your TV Guide collection in our
house
did she do quotes because it is a TV
Guide collection
um
yeah she did can I say something too why
not it's a podcast here's not it's gonna
be I'm gonna say something you know how
we all know that it's Frankenstein's
monster yes
yes the modern the 2022 version of that
style of joke is pointing out why did
you do air quotes that's literally what
it is that's the 2020
wait what's the 20 20 22. you still
haven't said
what is it 2022 what wait the the
explain that joke to me
da da
oh yeah
[Music]